(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
What a lovely welcome.
And to see you here live in the studio.
- I know. I don't know
if you remember this
first time we met, it was
actually on a red carpet.
- I know.
- It was was very quick.
- We bumped into each other.
- Yes.
- We were both in awe of each other.
- And I literally was like,
is that how we were supposed to come out?
Was I supposed to look like that?
Were we all supposed to look like?
You looked unbelievably gorgeous.
Anyway, that's
I just remember you being so kind as well.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] But I wanna say Merry Christmas.
We are decorated for Christmas.
- I'm telling you, I'm with you.
I'm a huge Christmas.
(audience cheering)
- Me too.
- I love it. I love it. I love it.
- Oh my God.
Would you ever make
like a Christmas album?
Have you ever done anything like that?
'Cause you sing so well.
- With you I would.
- Fine.
- I'd come and sing with
you any day of the week.
- Don't offer.
(audience cheering)
- Well, I just, you such a beautiful voice
and I was like if you love
Christmas, I love Christmas too.